hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to universe sandbox now
I haven't played this game since the oh
it's so cool song came out I've only
played it once and I think that's
actually a tragedy because I I recently
came across some videos of this again I
was like oh man I really think this game
is cool like this game is just kind of
alright whoa hey whoa ease up there
Sonny Boy wow there's so much detail on
that look at that I didn't know the hell
was there before though the squiggles in
the Sun so it's been a while since I
played it again and uh yeah I thought
I'd just give it another go and I wanted
to do this a bit more objective-based oh
my god as far as it goes oh boy
whoa ah man this thing still blows my
mind I mean it's it's it's just like
it's not that crazy but it's kind of
crazy okay so there's a few things that
I wanted to do when I played this again
the last time I played this I didn't
really have an objective this time I
want to recreate a few events and also
create some events that are from
questions that I would have and I would
kind of like to see reproduce in a way
that is less destructive to our solar
system and leads to us all being dead oh
man look at all these objects you know
for the first time in a long time
I went out to Hawaii for my vacation I
could see the center of the Milky Way
like I could actually see it it's
something if the night is clear enough
and you don't have as much light
pollution and some people around the
world like this is a common thing but if
you look up at the sky you can actually
see the center of the galaxy this is
such a fascinating concept and and I
haven't seen it since I was a kid just
because it's been so like light
pollution in LA and stuff like that but
you can lose sight of this beautiful
like magnificent or inspiring sight
that's just available for everybody to
see up in the night sky the sheer
magnitude of that center of the galaxy
it not even comparing to the rest of the
universe like the sheer magnitude of
that center of the galaxy just that
milky arm spreading across the sky is
so immensely huge that you cannot
perceive it like the magnitude of it is
something that your brain tries to
process but it just does not go anywhere
near the truth of how tiny we are in
comparison to that object and it's not
even an object it's a collection of
objects and then beyond that it's just
one galaxy in a universe of billions of
galaxies but I could see that and it
kind of got me thinking like a I want to
play the skin so here I am ready to play
it again and so what I want to do like
in the beginning here what I really
really want to do is I want to reverse
time okay we're gonna go back in time
we're gonna go back in time really far
okay so what I'm doing right now is I'm
sending the solar system into a spiral
of death what we have here is a
simulation that's running faster than it
can mathematically collate so what's
gonna happen eventually is this is going
to get so unbelievably wonky as it
starts to lose its position that things
are going to drift farther and farther
of where they actually would be in an
accurate simulation and we're just going
to eventually fall apart you can see
like this this actual target is much
lower than what it should be I'm aiming
I'm aiming for yeah a hundred and
forty-five thousand years per second but
I think that's that's a little bit too
much let's let's get like I want it I
want to hit a nice nine hundred years
per second that's what I that's what I
would be going for I mean this is
blazing through it's now 1885 but I want
to go farther I want to go all the way
back to the beginning and the only way
to do that is to sacrifice some accuracy
otherwise I'm gonna be here forever so
I'm going to increase the max positional
error to let's make it a good old 10 m/s
that's how bad the positional can be so
let's keep it going
oh now what's interesting is this
movement here that's actually the
movement of the Sun through the galaxy
see the sun's not just in one spot it's
moving we all are I mean not just around
the Sun but our entire solar system is
moving around the galaxy in a big spiral
as the Milky Way twists and turns so do
we twist and turn upon it among the
billions and billions of stars that we
exist on but this is still not going
fast enough or faster oh and lots of
faster all right there we go now we're
picking up some speed oh my god that is
not right oh we're getting into some
kind of a spiral but we're moving faster
now a little bit faster but uh you know
it's uh is what it is so let's add
another zero to this bad boy no not
there on that side of the decimal
doesn't work anything okay whoa whoa oh
we are booking it back in time all right
we are gunning we're gunning back in
time way wickedly way way way fast so
I'm gonna pause this point and where are
we exactly what what oh what is uh what
is the current situation that's going on
here we've got a whole lot of nothing
let's let's tune it down let's go back
to one year a second let's try to make
this a little less crazy you know I
don't even know where earth is here
where's earth did we lose our there's
earth okay I think we might have lost
her oh my god we lost our earth oh no
earth wait um earth baby listen listen
uh whoa earth there you are okay
Earth okay you're being real optimistic
saying that it is zero zero zero zero
eighty and there's life on this planet
with lights and whatnot but you know
let's let's let's assume that you're
just being optimistic here okay so we've
officially destroyed the entirety of
everything we have reversed time into
the point where everything exploded yeah
it's no good so one of the things that I
wanted to explore was this topic that
there could be a moment where earth just
simply loses it like if the Sun were to
disappear okay if for whatever reasons
say a black hole or another star passed
close enough by our solar system to pull
the earth out of orbit or if the Sun
were to suddenly disappear completely
all of the planets would just like go
off instantaneously tangential to where
they were originally going with nothing
left to pull them down into the gravity
well the Sun nothing's gonna hold them
in orbit anymore therefore they
instantaneously just carry on the way
that we're going so what I want to do
now is I want to show you let's how do
we reset this whole shebang
all right so here we have the solar
system it is home the only home we'd
ever know and the only home that we got
right now what's gonna happen if I just
you know get rid of the Sun if say for
example the Sun just pause disappear
what would happen there they go all the
planets all the orbiting objects
everything that once was is now gone off
on its own Jupiter's going off on its
own all of the asteroids are going off
their own Uranus is off on its own as we
all know Neptune even Pluto gone off
into the cold dark depths of forever now
that we're at this point it's a little
too late but what if we were to suddenly
bring the Sun back let's say the sun's
gonna go right try to get it exactly
where it was point and there she is oh
whoops there she goes
oopsies ah wait oh no that's two suns
now that's not what I wanted okay that
is just regard damn dick ulis can you
okay now we got two suns in an orbit all
right not what I was hoping for but hey
you know I'm not complaining that is a
pretty sweet ballet okay so we got two
ballet ting Suns here going off in a
spiral and you can see that the other
objects in the solar system are suddenly
starting to be pulled back
not all of them Eartha seems to be
pretty well off on its own it might have
a slight curve towards ya it's got a
slight curve but I don't think it's ever
gonna return back but you never know
let's see what happens
Jupiter has made quite the turn yeah
Jupiter seems to be coming back the Sun
is desperately trying to orbit the other
Sun he be is caught up in the dance real
hardcore earth is still projected to
dance out that way for almost all
eternity but oh my god you can see its
projected line just with the dancing of
the sun's it doesn't know what it's
gonna be doing that's funny don't add
more Suns to this okay let's add another
Sun there oh whoa okay wait no it's not
good I just blew up everything holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay well supernova aside Wow oh
oh oh God
okay that that was a bigger boom than I
thought it was gonna be okay all right
okay all right okay that's that's not
good all right okay let's reset for a
second all right now I know what I'm
gonna be doing I have a good idea so
what I'm gonna be doing the most
fascinating thing that I see yeah
besides blowing up the entirety of the
Sun that's fun and all but I want to go
through as many ways as possible of
destroying the earth our home the only
home that we have and what worse fate
could befall it than to be subjected to
the forces of the cruel cruel universe
of which we live in it's not gonna be
fun it's not gonna be pretty but it's
going to be what we do here so I want to
focus on just old-fashioned Earth
removing all the other variables I mean
in this one we're gonna obviously like
we're not gonna be doing much but it's
just earth earth and it's lonely moon
let's imagine a few scenarios all right
everyone put your thinking caps on
so imagine Earth is here right it's fine
but I think one of the nightmare
scenarios is that the moon would
eventually just fall into earth one way
I can do that is actually just by making
earth way heavier it's
this looks Oh shirt Oh goodbye what the
hell happened
fragment did you scrape the earth Oh bit
too fast hang on away I didn't even see
it what the hell happened
all right go again oh is that oh well
incoming I guess Oh dad dad looks like
one of my Kerbal space program
trajectories gone horribly wrong you Shh
okay yep this one is not gonna go
farther it's gonna be in a decaying
orbit until it eventually just slams
into this thing
oh the fragments oh my god the gravity
of Earth is ripping the moon apart
that's so cool
the moon is literally being torn to
shreds which is probably bad because
these fragments are probably gonna be
slamming into Earth in no time flat but
besides that let's focus on the other
here in the now oh my god there's so
many fragments either way this is not
spelling good stuff for the earth the
earth is in a lot of trouble and oh here
comes oh my god the moon has an evil
glowing eye staring death right out
there though my god they're fragments
get pulled right off of the moon there's
a reason oh look at the shadow oh that's
cool yeah so that's what happens with
like Saturn's rings there's a certain
zone inside Saturn's gravity well where
objects orbiting it cannot stay in one
piece they cannot collate into an object
because their gravity is not strong
enough to fight against the forces of
like the orbital like trajectory of
being that close to something like
Saturn it gets torn to shreds like
what's happening to the moon right now
so even these fragments I think are
getting torn into even smaller fragments
so every time they get hit they get
ripped apart again which is creating I
believe a ring or at least it will
create a ring here comes the moon again
oh it's beautiful oh yeah more fragments
all right so let's just let this run for
a good while I'm gonna go up to 10 hours
a second it's just gonna run unless the
moon slams into the earth which I don't
think actually it's gonna do I think
it's gonna be a super elliptical orbit
and every time it passes by more and
more fragments are gonna be torn up each
of the fragments getting smaller and
spar it's like being run through a
blender and some of the fragments aren't
coming back like obviously those guys
ain't coming back but the ones that do
get caught in here they just keep
spiraling over and over again
that's so cool this is not what I
expected to happen oh they're coming
back the fragments are coming back oh
look at you guys oh look at you guys or
any of these guys coming back nope those
guys are out II the moon has lost a lot
of its mass the moon has lost almost
three powers of ten of its mass just
from being shredded in the Earth's
gravity I'm not a hundred percent sure
but I think the moon actually might be
getting closer and closer to this thing
whoa that one tore up into a bunch I
wonder if there's something I can do to
make the Earth's atmosphere larger oh
that's so cool
you can make green could we could we try
to simulate the terraforming of a planet
like could we terraform Mars Oh that'd
be nuts
okay that's next on my list that's next
on my list oh that's so cool okay so but
anyway let's try to make more atmosphere
let's say the atmosphere is going to be
larger it is now one magnitude larger
which I think should cause some of these
things to rub and therefore slow down
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna put the
kibosh on this I'm gonna raise the let's
go back to one I'm gonna raise the mass
to no not one hundred and twenty twenty
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay yeah Wow
oh wow that is that is causing a great
deal of destruction I I'm sorry oh boy
yeah wha Oh oh boy that's that's bad
okay well
I have a funcle' who have a funkalicious
feeling that the moon's gonna have some
to say about this real soon and by real
soon
I mean right about now slow slow slow
slow slow down there we go alright Moony
sorry it had to be like this but you
know how it'd be you know how it'd be
bub oh and before we hit let's make you
Massey er just just cuz you know you
gotta be what you once was you can't be
what you are you're you're just a
shrimpy boy now you got to be a big
beefy boy you know what I mean I think
the moon was bigger than that I'm pretty
sure alright Moony there you go not ask
more like a moon maybe even the moon was
a burger I think oh yeah no it's it's
that's about the size of the moon
alright now you may impact your we done
yeah we done yeah we all done yeah we
done oh my oh wow you know what this is
gonna do this is gonna form another moon
that's what this is gonna coalesce into
I bet that's gonna form another moon oh
no way it's gonna come never ride it's
just gonna cause a horrible ring of
destruction is that is that what's left
of the moon
wait what is what is that that is a very
there's a very round formation what the
heck oh my god oh my god it did
it formed another moon this one is 21
times the mass of the moon but this is
not the original moon they hit this is a
fragments that coalesced into this super
super hot ball of liquid rock and while
the earth is just burning alive oh my
god it is it is just a fire wave of
destruction it is still going oh my god
these are probably tidal waves of lava
kilometres high huh of the earth it's
like a perfectly oh my god that is
beautiful and horrible yeah and there's
more still crashing into it right now
but this guy is good I thought I thought
that was gonna be food no isshe's Oh
actually I mean what if I drop the
weight of the earth just just a bit
let's make it 15 let's make it 15 yeah
let's actually let's make it let's make
it down to 10 let's make it 10 see how
that does see now the orbits a little
bit bigger the earth is still getting
bombarded and that's okay but this is
now not going to impact again so let's
crank up the time while this is you know
this is currently dying but you know it
is what is about the earth you know it's
saying its swan song it's it's pretty
much done so so why not why not go a
little faster all right so all as if
this point all life has been wiped off
don't think that just cuz this sections
not on fire doesn't mean that
everything's dead there because
everything is very dead they're
extremely dead very dead all oceans
boiled off everything is just gone the
mantle is ruptured so the entire like
the entire surfaces is going to be
completely destabilized and all the
tectonic plates look right now the the
water is boiling off which is such a
cool feature I didn't know that they
could actually do that but the water is
boiling off and the water is now all
vapor all greenery is gone there's
nothing left but ash and dust and
there's another piece no that's the same
piece okay now this is the new moon this
is old Earth
it's New Moon and there you have it
these fragments are still gonna be
falling back down
we are very dead but what we got fair
trade is a new moon let's go up to one
hour a second okay oh that is just that
is just beautiful
this is just beautiful I don't think we
just got a moon I think we got our I
think we got a like a belt whoa look at
this guy
oh he's beefy oh that's a beefy piece oh
that is a big piece yep oh the earth is
just going to be unbelievably hot molten
lava surface for like four years I mean
we will figure out how many years Oh
fragments coming in yeah but this is our
new moon can i rename it name new moon
there we go
it's so cool that's so cool that's so
cool I mean with everyone's dad bears
all qahal well the fragments are
starting to cool down so they're gonna
lose some of their glow some things are
still impacting but yeah it's gonna be
like this for a long time so let's go
ahead let's go up to ten let's go up to
as fast as it'll go let's get some speed
out of this right the earth is starting
to cool on one side anyway it's still
really hot like really really really hot
but as it cools OH
some pieces of the new moon are being
pulled into the earth which is not gonna
do well for it I wonder if it'll ever
like get out of the lopsided orbit let's
reduce the mass of the earth back down
to a little bit more reasonable levels
and let's make the moon you know
let's make it almost equally a
difference okay so new moon where is New
Moon going
so New Moon's orbits still little
lopsided but it's the least it's going
around the earth the Earth Day is still
extremely hot way too hot to have any
water yet but weirdly enough I think
this is snow in some weird ecological
parts of this there is snow
I don't know where the lights coming
from but yeah still there that's cool
how's the new moon doing Newman's going
down oh it looks more like just a rock
well that's that's not fair
that's not fair I thought it'd be looks
more spherical oh come on now I'll
smooth out over a few millennia
it's only been 158 days according to the
simulation [ __ ] that's not long at all
all right what is the auto orbit do well
there we go
ooh orbit well that's nice now its orbit
then nice oh cool okay all right that
situation is done well that's that's one
way to kill the earth I always do like
like different examples of that okay but
what I'm gonna do now is something a
little bit different instead of having
the moon pull itself into the earth I'm
gonna pull the earth into the moon we're
gonna make this bad boy we're gonna make
this bad boy literally a hundred moons
big let's make it even bigger let's make
it even bigger it's only one of earth
let's make it let's make it a hundred
earths who's a big boy who's a big boy
who's who's a big boy let's make it even
bigger let's make this bad boy a
thousand earths whoa who's a big boy
Odessa Odessa moon all right okay so
hoof all right so this is what I like to
call the super moon you know you may
have heard of a super moon in terms of
you know
in terms of like it's pretty big tonight
now if this one it's uh it's um yeah
it's uh it's gonna kill us all so let's
see that in
motion so what's gonna happen the earth
is pretty much making a straight beeline
guys it is not even close it's not even
close to an elliptical that is straight
into the moon okay so this is a
nightmare scenario imagine there was
some crazy scientists that found a way
to increase both the size and the mass
of the moon
cuz you know they don't have to
necessarily be the same thing but little
ol earth everyone you know and love oh
[Laughter]
geez that was uh impactful oh oh now
it's your turn moon and now you get
burned to a crisp but you know it's okay
the moon is now to the moon is now three
times the size of Jupiter and and she's
a burnin oh she's a burning bright
alright let's speed her up okay there we
go BLAP all right cool well that is um
not good it's a firestorm but that's
okay alright but while we're at this oh
maybe we could maybe we could terraform
this bad boy
she's real hot 7700 degrees that's real
hot but I don't think we're gonna be
able to terraform this oh wow that's hot
wait why are you getting hotter what
wait what's happening
the moon's shrinking the moon the moon
is collapsing in on itself oh oh oh it's
gonna start fusion eventually oh my god
what's gonna happen when it hits that
point what's gonna happen I mean right
now it's not it's not really a star it's
it's just it's a very very very like
dense planet that doesn't mean that it's
not going to the densities falling off
but that doesn't mean that it's it's
still going up that's crazy
okay let's speed it up just a little bit
well she is bright I love this I love
this so much I don't know if she's gonna
make a diffusion density I don't know
what the dense
okay density is now falling off pretty
good okay is that because I increase the
gravity did the gravity actually
increase is that just me being crazy
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna add
things to this until it gets you know
the right thing how big is Jupiter
Beckett Jupiter is technically bigger
than this but this is three times the
mass of Jupiter I mean that I think
that's what makes it like fascinating
okay let's add let's add some clothes
Herbet or earths okay would never mind
then too close too close oh boy oh well
that's that's fun
okay we got some earths ah now what I
intended to do humanity died a long time
ago but I think I think this is just
overkill at this point alright I'm gonna
jump the mass of this to four to swallow
these up swallow oh yeah okay so the
mass is actually the density is actually
decreasing which is fascinating that's
weird the density is decreasing probably
as it cools ah a weird it's gonna settle
into some kind of bizarre like it's
gonna actually cool down the surface
gravity is immense but it's cooling down
so I went off on a weird tangent I I was
I know I'm trying to destroy the earth
here but just I went on a fun a tangent
because I couldn't help it this is so
cool okay so she's cooling down pretty
good but that's not what I want she's
burnt she's a little toasty a little
toasted a little little burnt on the
edges let's make this five let's go five
whoo not what did I just do it turned
into it how did you do 500 I said five
okay the density just the density went
nuts I don't know what happened okay I
wanted to go five but it went to 500 for
some reason okay so she's not she's not
done she ain't done yet
but she's doing pretty good but I'm not
done yet
tools material ah hydrogen cool I don't
know what this is doing for the moon but
you know shooting hydrogen at it oh she
just turned into a gas giant
what the hell well that's so weird
oh never mind yo she back there she is
the moon is now a beautiful blue gas
giant with clot you can see oh that's so
nice and I love that so much that's so
nice let's get some water in there
okay that might have been enough ooh it
is getting toasty okay the density is
definitely going up who's getting hot oh
it's always getting hot oh it's getting
hot and it's getting toasty oh oh she's
heating up good
I love the band's just the like bands
are those simulated those simulated
bands based on like the density of it
like and what it actually because it's
these really harsh spirals of heat so
cool oh it just it just wore ho she just
went solar oh she just went solar and
then suddenly the moon is now a star oh
and you can ride along the surface of it
oh my god that's real cool okay anyway
alright enough of that I just got
distracted I'm trying to blow up throw
to blow up earth climate simulation ooh
wait climate simulation what would that
do what no way what I don't know what
could do that what the hell that's so
cool
so let's imagine just for a bit I'm
going to add this is another way that we
can destroy the world we're gonna add
just two gosh-darn much let's not make
it earths let's just do let's do uh
kilograms no not that much let's do a
thousand kilograms there we go
it's going we're going to
lovely let's go one day a second you
know let's add us some carbon dioxide
okay this is gonna do next to nothing to
the earth so let's try to at least make
it some kind of considerable oh the
earth is okay well that all right there
you go the earth just got [ __ ] its God
yeah okay and the earth destroyed
checkbox' done there I think the UH the
what threw me off there was just like
yeah what threw me off was everything
another big fear is that for some reason
somehow someway we create a black hole
on earth now not just any black hole
because these are big black holes what I
want is I want a black hole that is tiny
a tiny itty bitty black hole so let's
pause this and imagine just imagine that
in the centre of the earth was a black
hole now the black hole is there I might
actually reduce the mass of this black
hole to 0.01 the mass of the Sun which
is still considerable it's about ten
Jupiter's actually let's even make that
smaller let's make that point one
Jupiter's it's a small black hole but a
black hole it still is even smaller than
that let's go ten Earth's tiny black
hole by comparison but we make it
somehow in the center of our earth is a
black hole
so let's reduce this down to the seconds
I'm gonna go one second at a time and
see what nevermind it's gone okay jeez I
don't think that's go but alright whoa
that's cool alright wait back up a
second back up a second oh god I don't
think that's what would happen but you
know yeah that's just odd alright so
let's try this again we're gonna go one
minute per second we're gonna add a
black hole right here black hole Sun
won't you come wash away the pain it's
gonna be the size of Earth
what happens as you can see not very
much oh wait we got something what is
this what was that I don't know what
that is what is that what are these what
are all these dots what is happening oh
oh oh the the water is getting pulled
off of the earth is that what is that
what that is oh oh oh oh she's oh she's
she's a goner
oh oh she's a she's a goner all the
water just got ripped off of the earth
every drop of it probably the atmosphere
to surface temp is now 2,000 degrees
just from that pass pieces of the earth
huge pieces this is it this is an
enormous enormous about point at 2% the
size of the moon pieces of the earth 2%
the size of the Moon are being ripped
straight out of africa by a black hole
the size of one earth and then this is
going to go into the earth right about
there
I speed it up a bit and she's oh it's
impacting back down yep this black hole
did did quite a number on yield earth
here hoo hoo hoo Nelly oh well there she
goes there she goes there she goes the
second pass turns out to be much much
much more destructive oh ma oh mama
Jambo the earth don't look so good there
the earth yeah at earth um yeah that's
uh Wow Oh
oh my oh holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay so
where do the whys don't make black holes
throw them's bad news them's just bad
news all around
oh my computer is struggling lesson
learned
don't uh don't do that oh that's a
pretty sight though oh look at this the
echoing shock waves just on the earth
that's crash
in there that's dunzo oh my god
that's so cool alright so that's one way
now what else I'm gonna do let's load
back up ye olde earth again this poor
earth I'm subjecting it to so much
horrors alright so what am I do is I'm
gonna turn this moon into a black hole
in procedural steps we're gonna go I'm
not gonna mess with its mass at all I'm
gonna mess with its density it's uh
let's say it's calculated radius that's
gonna be on I'm gonna make its density
now 100 grams per centum centimeter
squared so it's now much more dense
right he's a dense ball he's the dense
ball but it's still not so bad alright
let's go a thousand bonk
she's tinier is much smaller she's much
smaller but not to buy it okay let's go
ten thousand all right dying here she's
getting teensy tiny now now see the
orbit will not be changed in any way cuz
it's still the same mass same exact mass
so the orbits not gonna go any
differently but if we keep cranking her
down not the earth no thank you
keep cranking her down let's go another
one point again Blanc and tints it died
near very very tiny super tiny very
dense very dense okay let's go one more
then very dense very very dense okay
let's go even tinier dance oh she's so
dance moon is now tiny tiny the moon is
56 centimeters across its surface
gravity is one point five six times 10
to the 13th meter per second which
technically should be faster than the
speed of light very very faster so this
should have turned into a black hole but
it hasn't for some reason so let's go
even further okay where's the moon
there's the moon okay there we go
the moon is now disappeared it is 0.026
let's crank it back down a bit
so this simulation was correct it this
should be a black hole it is basically
the equivalent of a black hole it is
super dense it should not exist that way
and yeah it's uh that's pretty crazy
okay this is now five point six
millimeters this is the size of a bullet
but same exact orbit same exact orbit
because nothing's changed about the mass
of it now what would happen if I did
change the mass of it right so it's
radius I'm gonna lock it I'm gonna lock
the radius lock that radius off done
that chains a mess there we go it is now
become the black hole because I changed
the mass of it and I wasn't supposed to
do that but it's now a black hole just
sucked in all all the matter down to a
singularity light can't even escape it
but it's a black hole now so does that
mean it changed anything about the orbit
from the earth
apparently yes which isn't necessarily
supposed to be true that's not
necessarily supposed to be how that
happens not I represent sure why cuz
even if it was a black hole it shouldn't
be any different you know what I mean oh
but I did increase the mass of it that
that's what happened okay so what I'm
doing now is I've created a new galaxy
basically there we are okay so I just
spawned a new galaxy on top of Earth
pretty much on top of it's not right
there but this one's got some dark
matter so that's not gonna go well
basically dark matter who honestly knows
what it is no one knows what it is no
one knows what it does but there's also
a supermassive black hole in the center
right here so that is gonna do a number
on earthy boy right here so let's just
see where she's going oh she's going
dead into the okay well that's not good
well let's see what happens huh
as hilarious as it is to have this moon
like that I'm gonna just
okay I'm gonna think of a stop it for a
moment just cuz very hard to keep this
uh this this idea going okay just gonna
get rid of the moon for now sorry moon
you Audi oh and we off we off like a
rocket apparently we're gone three
thousand years a second we were going
three thousand years a second yes plug
that takes a real long time still to get
to the supermassive black hole but we're
going at three alright so just imagine
everyone is able to live long enough to
panic for over a hundred thousand years
now as we journey to the center of this
supermassive black hole there we've made
it almost no distance alright we need to
jump it up a little bit we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna go a hundred
thousand years a second and we are just
barely making progress at a hundred
thousand years per second we are just
starting to make some progress let's
make that five hundred thousand years
per second okay we're very close to our
destination apparently or near some dark
matter I don't know where the black hole
is but uh you know I have a funny
feeling it's real close okay I think I
missed it where the hell did the we're
the supermassive black hole go you know
the supermassive black hole that I was
looking at it we passed it we somehow oh
we're off cigar cigar Oh cigar is the
name of the galaxy okay alright that's
funny alright so we made it guys good
job
everybody be happy oh [ __ ] never mind we
are a nice ball we are a ball of ice
where there is no life not even it but
we are some persistent sons of [ __ ]
are we yeah we're tenacious
alright baby way that's that's that
apparently the next way that we're all
gonna die is by making the Sun go
supernova
now technically
I think the Sun is supposed to go
supernova but I don't think that's
supposed to be going anytime soon but
you know let's just say that this bad
boy he's gonna go kaboom me real hard
gravity weight was gravity not on what
was gravity not on what since when was
gravity not on where is gravity not on
Oh
Uriel explode we're gonna make this bad
boy explode we're gonna explode you get
ready for explody it let's slow it down
to by the hour and let's explode uh yeah
let's explode you bang ok supernova it
has begun we're going by the let's go by
the minute actually 1 minute per second
I go and we're kabooming and work
kabooming and we can see the view from
Earth as a spectacular explosion ooh
it's real pretty as it comes to destroy
all of your money and as the blast gets
closer and closer we're already heating
up more and more so you know that's
something to look forward to
ok if we watch very closely it looks
like a big old eyeball but instead of an
eyeball it's red hot death exploding
towards us very quickly the oceans have
started to boil away which is always a
good sign
the supernova has almost engulfed us it
is very very scary okay we are just
crossing the threshold of the supernova
we are now 300 we're now 400 degrees
Celsius surface temperature there's
still some ocean left which is very
shocking to be perfectly honest surface
temperatures approaching 700 degrees
hell yeah it's like an oven in here even
hotter than it was before in Africa but
now it's really a lot we didn't even
know there was a chain like that that's
cool well let's step it up a bit we're
gonna go 10 minutes earth is 2,000
degrees I feel like in 3000 oh God okay
it's roasting alright we are starting to
become incinerated by the expanding
supernova these supernovae it has like
now officially we're I think we could
definitely be
we are 9,000 degrees we are 10,000
degrees we are all continents have lost
all shape or form they are very oh the
earth is contracting oddly enough is
she's getting smaller I guess by the
temperature is like causing it to be
more dense oh she's oh no I think she's
no she's just bleeding off all of its
mass is literally exploding off of it oh
that's what's happening okay the earth
is shrinking because it is losing
everything that it once was and it is
now going going going going going going
and she's gone
she gone baby
how's Mars doing how's Mars bars doing
oh not any better she's roasting I just
got over here to say Mars uh go off into
the sunset and goodbye Mars and the
supernova has claimed us all we are all
dead and we will never ever live again
because we're dead
fun times what is happening here I don't
feel like this is a good thing whatever
is happening here and I'm not sure what
happened here but whatever's happening
here oh yeah that's that's not good yeah
that's okay we reach in line to go into
Jupiter even Oh Oh God
oh no I came at a bad time
chubowski asha boosts Keyshia Bull okay
that's one way for earth to die I don't
know who put us like this but that's
definitely a way for earth to die and
the winner is Jupiter all right there
you have it not what I was hoping for
but and that happened all right so now
that we've killed the earth over and
over again let's do something else let's
do something a little more fun I want to
try to terraform Mars okay so here's how
we're gonna do this Mars is an ice
planet it's not quite as big as Earth it
doesn't have anywhere near the
atmosphere and as far as we know it
doesn't have an iron core but that
doesn't mean that it can't sustain life
at some point it's got not much of an
atmosphere but it's got some of an
atmosphere it's got all the basic
building blocks of life it just doesn't
necessarily have what it needs to keep
life that's the thing
iron silicate water and hydrogen okay
let's make it more water
let's make just a little more water
let's make it make it like that much
water so we got water there but it's
mostly ice right now so what we need to
do is we need to give it more iron as
well let's give it more iron one more
power of 10 more iron there we go now it
has an iron core
all right we're gonna turn climate on
just to give this simulation some oomph
huh so that is a start but in order to
do this more we're going to need to
figure out a way to get this thing a
magneto sphere now apparently there is a
way to create a magnetosphere but I'm
not a Harbison sure how to do it so I've
got it an iron core but I don't know if
that's gonna do anything to the
magnetosphere and in fact we've lost a
lot of similarity to to earth but that's
okay we had a chance of life before but
it's all gone now but that's fine don't
worry about that because we're gonna
change this up for the better what we
need to do is we need to add some carbon
dioxide because what it doesn't have
what it doesn't have it anyway
is an atmosphere it needs an atmosphere
it's got no atmosphere right now very
none atmosphere in fact I think I
accidentally destroyed all the
atmosphere and that's why I can't do
anything right now but I'm gonna add
some atmosphere to it in fact I'm just
gonna add some right here let's add a
hundred thousand kilograms of atmosphere
that's not gonna do a whole lot nope
apparently we're not gonna add a hundred
thousand kilograms of atmosphere maybe I
just need to add carbon dioxide okay
we're gonna add carbon dioxide we're
gonna add a hundred thousand current
kilograms of carbon dioxide at a time
actually I'm going to restart this okay
we're gonna start again oh let's go one
hour at a time all right there we go
that's a nice planet that's real nice
right there that's a real nice planet so
what we got here is we got a little
problem it doesn't have nearly as much
anything that we need and we do need it
to have things so let's turn on the
climate let's turn that on let's turn on
the visualization of the magnetosphere
which we don't have not yet anyway and
let's change the composition to a little
more iron and then there's water in
there there is water in there
let me just raise it up just a bit more
there we go that's just enough water
we're not gonna mess with the hydrogen
because apparently that just blows up
the atmosphere instantaneously and we're
not gonna do that yet we have other
things that we're going to do it will
not just get
as far as I know but life likelihood is
now a little bit higher yeah oh that's
pretty good so we need to give it more
atmosphere so how do we do that so the
temperature is going to be trending
upwards what this is gonna need is is
gonna need a lot more atmosphere than
say other things have so let me see if
adding carbon dioxide is just going to
ruin this I also got to remember that a
hundred thousand kilograms of anything
is not a lot when it comes to the entire
planet so let's add even more carbon
dioxide there we go okay
I gave it a magnetosphere cool well
that's the first thing that we needed we
definitely needed that so increasing
chance of life has gone up a little bit
alright so now we got to kick it up a
notch
we got we got kind of the basic cell but
we got an atmosphere a little bit not
not a lot of it and I mean we could have
more atmosphere obviously and let's make
a little more atmosphere here we go oh
[ __ ] the greenhouse effect is real high
on that that's probably too high what is
let me let me compared to earth what is
what is Earth's greenhouse effect on all
that stuff ah okay good
okay there we go I think that's just
about right alright so we're getting
better
we've got definitely a denser atmosphere
let's show that turn off the
magnetosphere the surface temperature is
not great but we can improve it by
actually uh and this may sound
counterintuitive but we can improve it
by throwing things at the planet so
we're gonna just throw a random asteroid
never mind that was faster than I
thought okay didn't think that was gonna
be like that let's keep this down to the
minute shall we okay random asteroid
Chuck that bad boy over there
boom all right so I'm gonna let that
cook for a bit we're gonna let that cook
toss it in the oven for a few days and
she's gonna really think about that one
and we're still going cold why are we
going cold I was it cuz we're going
farther away from the Sun okay so we're
gonna need what is what is the surface
pressure around ninety eight point two
okay so we need to crank up the surface
pressure of of Mars four boom one
atmosphere on the dot at 1.01 that's
better so now we're gonna have a much
more pronounced greenhouse effect we're
gonna be able to keep our temperature
relatively good and then we can heat
this bad boy up
excuse all the pockmarks had some bad
acne you know this is try small moon
there we go surface temperature is
higher BAM no one said this was easy
okay I'm resetting whoa that is too much
water okay that's way too much water
all right let's tone down the water
there gents tone down the water whoa on
the water ease up on the water I don't
know what that's all about but that's
happening okay we've got the beginnings
of clouds just the beginnings so what
I'm going to do is I'm gonna increase
the surface temperature to ten degrees
Celsius that is a big shift from what it
once was and it's got a little bit of an
atmosphere to keep that but that doesn't
mean that it's gonna stay that way
we just took out the big ass scars and
stuff but we're gonna ignore that I
didn't actually need to do that but we
are going to pretend like it was
necessary all right and would you look
at that we've got some clouds forming so
it's still cold but it should be able to
keep its temperature once it's able to
start melting and and like growing some
clouds clouds are reflective and stuff
and they can keep it cool but also like
the the engine of water changing it
states can be self-sustaining in a way
so hopefully that's going to help it in
the long run okay now I'm going to
increase its mass
now this may ruin everything else but
I'm just gonna increase its mass by
about double I'm gonna double its mass
roughly so in doing that it changes up a
lot of things about it suddenly the
gravity is more intense is able to hold
its atmosphere a little bit better you
know what I mean so if it's able to hold
its atmosphere better it'll lose less to
the surrounding space it'll radiate out
less the main problem with with Mars is
that it doesn't necessarily get that
much heat from the Sun you know what I
mean
so we're almost where we need to be the
only problem now is it's not able to
hold its temperature now in order to get
it sold its temperature I'm hoping that
adding carbon dioxide we'll be able to
do such a feat if not well then we've
got more of a problem but I think this
should be able to help it along that's
increasing its mess
incredibly I raised this mass to earth
levels which I don't go to bad I don't
know seems to be okay why is the
greenhouse effect going down if I had
carbon dioxide that's dumb oh that's
dumb huh okay well no god damn it
okay and that is about as good as I can
get it I think I've gone why are we
looking over there don't look over there
you're gonna reveal my secret so I
couldn't get it to have the right
reflectivity if it was too far away from
the Sun so I had to move it closer
basically it's between Earth and Venus
now not really practical but then again
nothing else I was doing it was exactly
practical like raising the mass of the
entire planet but that's about it so I
made life and anyway I'm gonna blow it
up because I can't stand to even think
about that so kaboom ah oh wow you were
gone fast I was thinking that there was
gonna be like a little more time but
anyway earth let's look at earth blow up
to say goodbye here so this has been
universe an Box I've been playing around
like way longer than I thought I would
I've just been having a crazy amount of
fun thank you everybody so much for
watching really do appreciate you guys
being here and just thanks so much for
watching I uh yeah I just love space so
much whoa there she goes oh oh so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
know I've said that like 15 times now
but just thank you if you got any other
games you want me to play please write
them down in the comments below let me
know what you thinking if you got other
ways that you want to blow up earth let
me know down in the comments as well and
if you want to hit the join button and
help support this channel and help me
make cool stuff the links right down
there thanks again everybody so much for
watching one more time and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
what happen if you blew up a black hole
oh whoa whoa I don't know what happened
there what happened okay it gone I guess
[Music]